[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israel heute gibt es mal kein rezept
video von mir das volk wieder morgen und
auch nächste woche am samstag verlade
ich immer gerne stanley und uhr videos
hoch zum beispiel oder berichte über
eine messe aber ich habe auch schon
andere themen angesprochen schöne themen
auch schon traurige themen und das video
heute ist im prinzip ein tolles video
aber auch traurig und ihr seht auch
schon ich bin ein bisschen gedrückt
ihr habt letztes jahr mitbekommen dass
ich viele kinder begleitet habe und ich
bekomme jeden tag wirklich hunderte e
mails und wirklich auch viele schicksale
oder viele menschen die von ihren
schicksalen berichten viele menschen die
meine hilfe benötigen
und ich lese auch alle e mail und kann
nur nicht auf alle antworten weil es
einfach zu viel ist weil sie auch jeden
tag arbeiten und einen haushalt haben
die kinder haben und ja und es sind
einfach viele menschen mit zum beispiel
also im nordischen mann geschrieben dass
eine frau zurückgewinnen möchte aber
schreiben mir zum beispiel auch eltern
die einen sterbenskranken kind haben und
das kind hat er den wunsch die sally
noch einmal zu treffen und ja viele
kinder die einfach nur die letzten
wünsche haben und oder freunde
freundinnen kameraden nachbarn lehrer
egal was und das bedrückt mich natürlich
sehr weil ich es selber auch kinder habe
und auch alle kinder in meiner umgebung
sehr liebe und ja ich will natürlich
jedem gerne helfen aber ich berichte aus
dem letzten jahr ich habe ihr letztes
jahr war auch für die größte aktion
haben habe ich gemeinsam mit murat zur
spende aufgerufen für ihr leider die
leukämie hatte und wir haben alle dazu
beigetragen und ihr habt alle auch gott
erst so viel gespendet wir konnten die
leider wirklich die therapie in amerika
ermöglichen innviertel und fährt dann
leider doch nicht geschafft und hat
leider den kampf gegen den krebs
verloren
[Musik]
und ich habe auch letztes jahr die hanna
kennen gelernt sechs jahre alt aussehen
dann habe ich die maike kennengelernt 16
oder 17
also alle drei hatten etwas gemeinsam
alle 13 gestoppt
und ich habe bei allen drei geholfen das
heißt die hanna durfte mich besuchen in
balingen bei der autogrammstunde und ich
hab mir dann zeit für sie genommen und
war schrecklich krank aus und ich hab
selber zwei kinder und das
horrorszenario für alle eltern für alle
tanten für alle großeltern ist immer
dass ein kind stirbt und dieses jahr vor
drei wochen da waren wir gerade
unterwegs haben wir die nachricht
gekriegt dass die ganze gestorben ist
ganze hatte keine leukämie sie war
sie hatte von geburt an eine unheilbare
krankheit und im alter von 17 jahren
gestorben
und das belastet mich natürlich sehr und
ich möchte überall helfen aber ich kann
nicht allen helfen dachte ich zumindest
immer mit euch vorstellen es gibt in
deutschland allein 70.000 kinder der
unheilbaren ebene lebensverkürzenden
krankheit haben
und wenn ich mir das vorstelle 40.000
ich wohne in waghäusel und da wurden
etwa 20.000 menschen und das ist doppelt
so viel und es sind kinder die einfach
niemals erwachsen werden das heißt wir
werden ihre familien bereits im
kindesalter machen und es gibt einfach
den bundesverband kinderhospiz der
unterstützt diese familien unterstützt
die kinder und die betroffenen
finanziell fahrt auch noch eine
beerdigung aber vor allem sind wir auch
da um zu beraten um ansprechpartner zu
finden
und ja ein kinderhospiz das dachte ich
auch immer dass es ein ort ist zum
sterben mit dass die kinder dahingehend
zum sterben aber es ist einfach so wenn
auch gerade im jungen alter die kinder
schon die diagnose bekommen haben
wir sind krank dass die dann auch
während der erkrankung mehrmals hingehen
und es gibt in deutschland etwa 14
stationäre kinderhospize und es wird mir
so gesagt als ich habe auch den kontakt
gesucht und ich würde auch kontaktiert
vom bundesverband kinderhospiz ist nicht
nur ein ort zum sterben sondern auch ein
ort das leben und das lachen und das
sind viele ausgebildete menschen die
einfach den familien helfen und die
familien unterstützen weil es einfach
ja ich meine oma du nicht mein traum war
es immer
mit etwa mitte 20 spätestens mama zu
werden und vor dem 30 lebensjahr ein
haus zu bauen mit meinen eltern zusammen
zu wohnen und jeder hat träume und dann
bekommt sie plötzlich die diagnose dein
kind wird sterben und es wird nicht
erwachsen werden und das wirft alles aus
der bahn also all deine lebensplanung
ist kaputt und du kannst nicht mehr in
urlaub gehen weil es nicht einfach
belastet dein kind wird bald von dieser
welt gehen und du weißt gar nicht was
soll ich jetzt tun soll ich mit meinem
kind noch alles erleben wie verkraften
die geschwisterkinder und es ist
furchtbar also das schlimmste finde ich
was einem menschen überhaupt noch sehen
kann man kann sich einfach wieder
einfach bisschen abschalten dann zur
arbeit gehen und eine normales leben
führen
das ist nicht möglich und sagt da sind
die banken die kinderfüße da wie gesagt
sie können natürlich steht auch mein
kind kinder gehen auch zum sterben hin
aber es gibt auch kinder die möchten
dort nicht sterben die gehen dann wieder
nach hause und geht ihm das bietet dann
da um sie zu unterstützen
jetzt habt ihr wahrscheinlich die zahl
im kopf als 40.000 kinder im jahr
oder er ist in 4000 kinder in
deutschland die sterbenskranken etwa
5000 sterben pro jahr und es gibt nur
solche notizen von 12 oder 14 14
kinderhospize starten und es gibt 200
ambulante das heißt dass ihm dann
ehrenamtlicher die ausgebildet werden
und für den familien nach hause gehen
die beraten unterstützen anlaufstellen
und so weiter finden aber es gab bisher
keine organisation und vorsicht einfach
alle 40.000 schicksale und familien
hinwenden konnten
und da gibt's wars jetzt gibts da was
und zwar ist es im sorgentelefon und
sorgentelefon heißt aufgaben und ich
habe mir gedacht ich unterstütze diese
sorgentelefon weil ich so auch allem
allen kindern allen familienangehörigen
lehrern eltern helfen kann und wirklich
alle was davon haben und es ist wirklich
ein ganz ganz tolles projekt und dafür
möchte ich euch heute erzählen vor allem
könnt ihr auch dazu beitragen auch mit
geringstem aufwand wirklich so kann
jeder machen jeder von euch kann
mithelfen
auch wenn ihr jetzt sagt ich habe keine
finanzielle unterstützung ist es mir
nicht möglich könnt ihr trotzdem hin
von uns kommen wirklich alle tore kurz
zeigen was oskar ist genau wir zeigen
euch jetzt ganz gut macht aufgabe
sorgentelefon ist und ich würde mich
noch mal kurz
ich bin mir und ich falle
weil ich sehr krank bin und bald sterben
muss
zum glück habe ich ein bruder der mich
hält
[Musik]
ehrlich ich habe ganz schön angst in
diesem fall aber unsere eltern sind ja
da und die haben auf alles eine antwort
genau werden für alles eine antwort
unsere kinder brauchen uns
ich wünschte das wäre zu einfach
manchmal weiß ich überhaupt nicht weiter
aber dann kann ich mich an meinen mann
festhalten
und wer eltern mich wir brauchen
jemanden der uns hält sonst zerbricht
für alles
an
einen grund
[Musik]
in den schlimmsten stürme hilft uns
oskar versorgen und infotelefon für
familien mit unheilbar kranken kindern
die sterben müssen und der 0 800 88 88
47 11 ist jemand rund um die uhr
erreichbar
für alle die hilfe brauchen auch in der
trauer auch für euch auf der kann nur
durch spenden überleben helfen auch sie
ja das video wasser
ich war das erste mal ich hab auch
schockiert als ich gesehen habe aber so
ist es einfach also wenn man die
diagnose kommt dann fällt man und fällt
und fällt und hat einfach nicht auch
machen angst die ganze zeit und es ist
keiner da der einen auffängt und ich
finde es richtig gut getroffen der murat
hat mich angeguckt das tier auf dem sofa
und dann kam ihre aus ihrem zimmer und
ich hatte murat macht ausmacht aus
schnell und habe mir gedacht als sie
dann gleich so mit großen augen da stand
und gehört hat mama ich muss sterben und
das kind hat es einfach und ich wollte
eigentlich nicht dass wir damit
konfrontiert wird und angst bekommt und
dann holten im nächsten moment gedacht
aber so ist eben das leben also
irgendwann muthmann damit konfrontiert
werden bei mir war es so ich habe vor
drei jahren war mein erster todesfall
mein opa gleich im alter von 92 jahren
gestorben
ich war 26 25 26 und es war für mich
schon
der schock aber da habe ich dann
irgendwann habe ich damit ich gewusst
wie ich damit umgehen muss ich dachte
okay das ist der verlauf des lebens die
älteren menschen verlassen die erde
zuerst und kinder werden erwachsen und
wenn ein kind auf dem leben dieses ist
es einfach macht völlig anderes und ja
und ich denke da müssen kinder einfach
auch lernen damit umzugehen dafür ist
auch oft harte folgen telefon dar
ich bin zum beispiel auch schon fall für
oscar ein wort die ganzen e mails immer
lese die kinder kennen gelernt habt die
angehörigen die geschwisterkinder und
ich weiß selber nicht so ganz wie ich
damit umgehen soll das belastet mich
sehr ich träume davon und ich liege im
bett und denkt immer mensch die flasche
von stressigen tag gehabt und mach dir
gedanken darüber wann bringe ich das
auto zur waschanlage und eigentlich ist
alles ganz wichtig und ja es ist einfach
klar das muss ich da irgend auch nicht
aus dem konzept bringen lassen
trotzdem plant das leben geht weiter
aber für diese familien eben nicht und
ich verstehe wenn die familie samstagen
für uns hat die welt aufgehört sich zu
drehen und dafür ist flattr und das muss
einfach unterstützt werden oscar lebt
von spendengeldern das sind fachkräfte
das sind psychosoziale fachkräfte dass
im notfall seelsorger trauerbegleiter
ausgebildete menschen auch mitglieder
des bundesverbandes kinderhaus geht und
das muss einfach aufrecht erhalten
werden und die familien haben einfach
die möglichkeit 24 stunden am tag an
feiertagen wirklich rund um die uhr per
telefon besetzt
ihr könnt ja anrufen er könnte fragen
stellen
manchmal fragen kinder dinge cisco
systems inc kindertagen und du hast die
antworten keine antworten mehr und so
wie im video auch geschrieben die kinder
wendet sich an mama und papa die mama
hält noch ein papa fest und an gm hält
aber fest vielleicht ja es gibt einfach
familien da zerbricht die familie
ich kann mir auch vorstellen gerade bei
familien nur mit nur einem kind wenn sie
dieses eine kind verlieren das
vielleicht auch eine beziehung kaputt
gehen kann tragen weil man sich einfach
nicht zu helfen weil es sind geschwister
kinder die darunter leiden deren
kindheit ist dann auch irgendwo kaputt
ich weiß zum beispiel dass ihr leid dass
schwester hat die arena die war ganz
lange nicht ob der schule aber die
eltern die lehrer dämpfe total
unterstützt
es ging einfach nicht die waren die
ganze zeit in diesem elternhaus sie
wollte die familie unterstützen bei
ihrer schwester sein und es ist wirklich
einfach furchtbar kann sich das gar
nicht vorstellen und ja jedenfalls haben
nur zu bekommen was können wir tun was
mache ich am liebsten natürlich backen
und kochen und ich habe mir gedacht komm
wir machen jetzt ein buch ein kinderbuch
sowie mein erstes buch rezepte für
kinder und in diesem buch möchte ich
gerne alle alle rezepte sammeln die
wirklich toll sind rezepte für kinder
aber die rezepte sind nicht nur für
kinder auch über meine ersten buchs man
einfach einfache rezepte vom frühstück
das mittagessen bis zum abendessen oder
bisher verfettete jeder machen kann
jeden tag
rezepte aus dem kind haid und dieses
buch soll dann verkauft werden und der
ganze erlös geht dann an dass oskar
sorgentelefon das soll einfach von uns
unser partner in dem wir beitragen
möchten und ihr müsst verstehen so ein
buch ist nicht schnell gemacht und ich
arbeite momentan auch noch an einem buch
machen wir eben dieses kinderbuch und es
ist wirklich ein wochenlanger
monatelanger prozess und wir möchten
gerne das buch am 19 september dieses
jahr auf der messe in freiburg d h
auf der badenmesse da bin ich zwei tage
mit meinem gesamten team mit meinem shop
mit meinem standen in meiner küche
dort möchten wir das buch erstmalig
vorstellen wir arbeiten alle
ehrenamtlich und der komplette erlös
geht an oskar
und jetzt brauche ich einfach eure
unterstützung ich habe natürlich schon
viele rezeptideen aber ich denke dass
viele viele von euch einfach ganz viele
tolle rezepte haben rezepte aus eurer
kindheit oder rappt bitte ihr dann mit
euren kindern zubereitet und die dürfte
mir gerne zu schicken
und ja ich werde auch meine
lieblingsrezepte aus der kindheit mit
reinpacken ich habe immer gerne und gut
gegessen wie joghurt war ganz einfach
war wie immer ganz einfach zuzubereiten
noch mal deinen dienst youtube
aber das ist doch kein gericht ist schon
fertig produktfoto jeder ire hatte doch
auf ihre kindheit sei in jeder der seine
kindheit ist geniale reparatur wo die
mama gemacht gemacht hat und die musste
das heißt wir irgendwie macht fotos mit
ihm und raimund jetzt alles was dem wohl
ihrer kinder in schreibt uns auf die
mailadresse haben eine e-mail-adresse
mit genau das wird jetzt hier
eingeblendet genauso eine extra
e-mail-adresse das heißt da könnt ihr
alle rezepte hinschicken
bitte seid verständnisvoll dass ich
nicht drauf antworten werde weil ich
hoffe natürlich dass jetzt viele viele
rezepte kommen und da werde ich die
rezepte waren die rezepte sofort
ausprobieren direkt ins buch mit rein
machen hier in unserer küche
fotografieren und wir werden uns
natürlich buch erwähnen was kriegen aber
erwähnen euch im buch zeigt ihr könnt
ihr eure kleine geschichte dazu
schreiben und das finde ich super schön
denn dann ist dieses buch nicht nur mein
buch nicht nur für die kinder sondern
das ist wirklich ein gemeinsames projekt
von uns und das finde ich super und ich
habe einfach das gefühl dass ich dann
allen gerecht werden kann ich kann allen
menschen damit helfen wenn alle können
sich ausgabe sorgentelefon wenden
ist euch vorstellen so viele schicksale
und nur so wenige kinderhospize und es
ist einfach eine zentrale anlaufstelle
oft auch wirklich einzigartig so was
gibt im vergleich gar nicht und ihr
könnt euch alle dahin wenden alle
anrufen und seit der entstehung also
seit dem letzten jahr haben wir
innerhalb von vier monaten über 400
rufe bekommen 400 schicksale 50 mal
bildlich vorstellen pro monat 100
schicksale am tag 33 familien deren
kinder sterbenskranken athletisch und
unglaublich und wie gesagt also alles
wird komplett gespendet
und wir werden jetzt noch unsere
kontakte spielen lassen wir versuchen
noch ohne neuerungen genau vielleicht
kennt den unternehmen gleichzeitig
geschäftsführer von einem unternehmen
ich habe zum beispiel de cuba
kontaktiert die haben gesagt egal was
wir sind mit dabei die machen auf jeden
fall mit unterstützen uns dabei ist will
man uns auch ins buch genau die
leistungen die hochrhein produkte genau
es gibt vielleicht auch kosten die haben
wir nicht in der hand die kosten drücken
und vielleicht schaffen es 23 vielleicht
sogar noch viel mehr jahre
wer das sorgentelefon sehr eigentlich
schön wenn dieses buch dazu beitragen
könnte dass man diese sorgentelefon
einfach ab jetzt für immer
aufrechterhalten könnte ja und alle die
da mitmachen als auch die sponsoren
kommen alle mit ins buch ein die firma
seltmann hat sich zb meldet die möchten
abgeblasen machen und das geld dann an
den spenden auch ein kinderhospiz band
und das ist eine aktion von der seiner
kinder hospiz stiftung
und ja es geht aber auch tolle
nachrichten
rubina zum beispiel aber es gibt auch
schicksale die positiv enden zum glück
setzt vor zwei wochen vor zwei drei
wochen war zum beispiel eine besucherin
aus der schweiz sagte cortina und sie
hatte auch krebs und hat den krebs
überwunden
und ja die stiftung hat er organisiert
dass sie den herzenswunsch erfüllt
bekommt und sie durfte mich hier
besuchen gemeinsam mit ihren schwestern
und die haben mich an einen tag lang
begleitet und es war für mich auch
einerseits sehr traurig weil ich dann
gesehen habt krass sein schicksal und
dann ja mal so jungen doch und für
jungen und was sie alles schon
mitgemacht haben die ganze familie es
geschafft und das war dann wieder
positiv also einfach schön ich würde
sowas auch gern öfter machen aber ist es
einfach nicht möglich vor allem ist echt
bedenken ich bin auch nur ein mensch ich
bin mama von zwei kindern
und wenn ich kranke kinder sehr artig
war mal in der uniklinik mit der ella
und war ich war da im wartezimmer und
das ist der horror
also wirklich darauf nehmen dass mit dem
bett und mittel meine träume und ich
muss das selber immer damit fertig
werden und deswegen kann ich so was auch
nicht regelmäßig machen auch wenn ich
gern machen würde aber ich bin einfach
nicht ausgebildet ich weiß nicht mal
selber wie ich mit der trauer klarkommen
und das macht mich fertig als ich denke
ihr könnt mich da auch bestimmt
verstehen und belastet mich und und
eigentlich will ich ja dass meine video
euch entlasten dass er mal abschalten
können
es sind auch viele die einfach sagen sie
gucken meine videos vergessen ihre
krankheit und das finde ich schön war's
mit agathe habt anderen videos
angeschaut und habe ich ihrem buch
gesteckt und dann habe ich das foto
gesehen dass mein buch eine erdbeertorte
gemacht hat rezepte wenn ihr unternehmen
seit und im buch mit drin sein wollt und
uns unterstützen möchte vielleicht ein
paar bücher kaufen möchte mitarbeiter
nicht an die gleiche e-mail-adresse
aufwenden genau von uns allen jetzt ganz
ganz viele ganz verschiedene gesetze als
rezept noch wichtig sagen bei den
rezepten wichtig bitte rezepte ohne
steckdose und so weiter ich mein ich
weiß war dann schon wie ich das ohne die
steckdose mache aber ja da könnt ihr mir
den weg auch ein bisschen einfacher
machen
er kann von mir aus fleisch drin sein
sogar egal ob ägypten freie der soll
ständig schmecken aber nichts fertiges
genau ich habe heute zum beispiel im
kindergarten weisheit morgen morgens
abschluss selbst bauen und wir haben den
kindern ganz tolle gesunde rezepte
gemacht gab so kleine erbse ball aus
bananen zitronensaft haferflocken und
war echt cool und hat allen kindern
geschmeckt und das ist halt auch ein
super coole rezept was es mit auf jeden
fall in dieses buch reinkommt ja ich
könnte jetzt noch viel drüber reden
heißes video teilte sieht auf jeden fall
damit wird noch viel möglich das ganze
lied ich freu mich auf eure rezepte und
ich zähle auf euch auf eure
unterstützung und ich denke mein sand
könnte wirklich super viel erreichen und
danke jetzt schon mal für eure
unterstützung und ich denke dass wir wie
beim letzten mal bei leider fehlte ruf
auch dieses mal ganz viel hilfe bekommen
vor allem weil wir jetzt wirklich allen
helfen können wirklich allen also seid
ihr dabei werde teilt diese aktion und
ich freue mich schon lange und fürs
zuschauen und mitmachen